[Music]
tuesday
january 1st 1856
with little pride and less hope
we begin the new year
[Music]
who is that good afternoon
i'm tally abigail
[Music]
i hope i'm not keeping you from
something i'm glad you've come
meeting you has made my day oh how
pleasant
and uncommon it is to make someone's day
i guess i'm supposed to offer a toast
what my husband means is he's so happy
to finally
get together do you miss me
yes our farm is a slaughterhouse right
now my husband is killing his hawks
and i resolved to visit you so that
there would be something in my day other
than his meanness
so what do you think what do you think
about this i don't know how to put it
into words
it's been my experience that it's not
always those who show the least
you actually feel at least
well seven an earthquake knocked down
our house we were born
an earthquake the dread never fully went
away
what was safe if the solid earth could
do that
[Music]
when the day is done my mind turns to
her
and i think why are we to be separated
i don't feel i have a wife i have
certain expectations and you have
certain duties
we shall sing like birds in the cage
we haven't seen you for days have you
been ill
it's happening are you in danger i would
die without you
do you want memories that i most cherish
it's if you're turning to me with that
smile
once you realized that you were loved
astonishment and joy
astonishment and joy
[Music]
you